ابدا هذه التغطيه من باريس معي من هناك
مراسل العربيه حسين فياض قنيبر حسين اهلا
وسهلا بك ينعاد عليك عقبال الميه انت من
الرعيل الاول الرعيل المؤسس لقناه العربيه
اولا بدايه اي كلمه في هذه المناسبات
عقدين على انطلاق قناه العربيه قبل ان
ابدا معك الحوار
الكلمه الاولى هو ان هذا النهار هو عيد
بالفعل هو ليس ذكرى الوسيله الاعلاميه لا
تصبح مجرد ذكرى الا اذا خالفت قيما
اعلاميه تحاول العربيه احترامها الى اقصى
حدود وهي التي ذكرتها في مقدمه النشره
الاولى لك طالب على العربيه والتي قلت
فيها انها قناه تحرص على الموضوعيه
والمهنيه والسرعه في نقل الخبر اذا اليوم
ليس ذكرى بل هو عيد رغم ان الالام حولنا
في العالم العربي تاتي من كل حب وصوب لكنه
عيد عيد انطلاقه محطه تحاول قدر الامكان
الحفاظ على نقل الامان المعلومه بامانه
الى المشاهد لان المراسل بمفهوم هو مجرد
شاهد ينقل الى المشاهد مشهدا عليه ان
ينقله بامانه وبدقه قبل كل شيء
انت من الاعلاميين والمراسلين المخضرمين
يعني لك باع طويل في اكثر من محطه سواء
تلفزيونيه واذاعيه وانضممت الى العربيه في
بدايتها
ناتي الان الى التجربه الشخصيه حسين لو
سمحت لي هل تذكر المره الاولى التي اطلت
بها على قناه العربيه مباشره وماذا كان
الموضوع
في الواقع كانت هناك تحضيرات في باريس
للتظاهره ضخمه تنديدا بما كان يحضر له من
اجتياحا للعراق تتذكر طالب وانت كنت على
النشرات حينها التي تحدثت عن هذه
التحضيرات الاجتياح الجوي اذا جاز التعبير
بدا في التاسع عشر من اذار مارس والبري في
العشرين منه قبل ذلك بايام تظاهر فارسيه
ضخمه طلب مني ان احضر تقريرا تجريبيا
بايلوت لا يبث فحضرت هذا البايلوت ولكن
المشرفين على
غرفه الاخبار ان يبث هذا التقرير عن
التظاهر الضخمه احتجاجا على ما يحضر له من
اجتياح للعراق وبث في نشره مسائيه كنت انت
تقدمها كان هذا اول عمل لي كنت اخشى من
وجود ثغرات في التقرير المصور وانا القادم
كما ذكرت من العمل
اذاعي كما ذكرت طالب في سؤالك انا قادم من
عمل اذاعي في اذاعه الشرق سنوات طويله
ولكن التقرير المصور في العربيه بث ولم
يكن مجرد تقرير تجريبي حسين يعني بتعرف
الاسئله التقليديه دائما في مثل هكذا
مناسبات اكثر لحظه مؤثره في حياتك المهنيه
عبر قناه العربيه ما هي اكيد المشاهد يريد
ان يعرف
كان هناك مسن عراقي عالق بين سياجين
شائكين عند الحدود الصربيه المجريه قال لي
انه مستعد للمخاطره بحياته للعبور نحو
اوروبا قالها وهو يبكي مسن سوري ايضا في
مليليه الجيب المغربي الذي تحتله اسبانيا
قال لي انا صاحب عمارات في حلب واعيش هنا
في خيمه اقصى طموحي هو الحصول على دواء
قلب لي سيده ايضا من دمشق غادرت دمشق كانت
عالقه عندها
بين المجر وصربيا قالت لي انها تريد
الحصول على قنينه ماء مشاهد كانت مؤثره
جدا كان عملنا عباره عن مقابلات سياسيه
وتغطيه مؤتمرات دوليه وتغطيه مفاوضات
سياسيه طويله الامد العربيه قامت في
البدايه على ما يمكن تسميته الخطاط
الاعلاميه كما تتذكرها جيدا في الاشهر
الاولى طالب وفي السنوات القليله الاولى
كانت الابرز من المقابله الحصريه التي
اجريتها مع الرئيس الفرنسي الراحل جاك
شيراك في قصر كانت اول مقابله حصريه
يعطيها رئيس فرنسي لقناه عربيه لكن
المقابله التي احدثت الدويه الاكبر في
المشهدين الاعلامي والسياسي كانت تلك التي
اجريتها للعربيه مع عبد الحليم خدام نائب
الرئيس السوري الذي كان واصلا للتو الى
باريس واعلن منهنا وخلال المقابله مع
العربيه انشقاقه عن النظام كانت هذه
المقابله التي احدثت الدوي الاكبر في حياه
ايضا هذا لن يمنعني من سؤالك اكثر لحظه
شعرت انه حياتك في خطر
خلال عملك في العربيه وفي التغطيه شعرت
انه خلص حياتك في خطر
طبعا لن اقول لك ابدا نطالب انها كانت
فتره تغطيه السترات الصفر في باريس هذه لم
تكن فيها مخاطره بالمعنى الحقيقي للكلمه
انما كانت في اوكرانيا التي توجهت اليها
مرتين قبل بدء الحرب
ومرتين خلال الحرب المره واحده خلال الحرب
قصف المطار وهو يقع قرب الفندق الذي كنت
انزل فيه واستيقظنا عند الخامسه صباحا على
قصف المطار حاولت المغادره فورا الى
الحدود البولنديه لكننا بقينا بعدها يومين
لمزيد من التغطيه بعد ذلك قصفت يافوريف
المجاوره لذيذ شعرنا
بخوف كبير طلبت من المصور بعدها المغادره
فورا نحو الحدود البولنديه لا اخفي عليك
انني لست مراسلا حربيا بارعا انا اخشى من
الحروب لانني عشت حربا كما تعرف طالب في
لبنان دامت 15 سنه طيب حسين ابرز
الوجوه او ابرز من تت ذكرهم اليوم في
العيد العشرين
اتذكر اولا الذين اضحوا بحياتهم من ضمن
طواقم العربيه حفاظا على رساله المحطه
وعلى الرساله الاعلاميه عموما اتذكرهم
فردا فردا لن اخوض في التسميات حتى لا
يعني ارتكب خطا نسياني احدهم اتذكر ايضا
الذين جرحوا او اصيبوا او فقدوا شيئا من
ذاتهم او من جسدهم او اصيبوا باعاقه هؤلاء
اتذكرهم جيدا اليوم واوجه التحيه لهم اذا
كانوا ما يزالون احياء ووجه تحيه الى
ذكراهم اذا كانوا اصبحوا في العالم الاخر
اتذكر الجنود المجهولين في العربيه الذين
يعني لا لا توجد مناسبه لكي نتحدث عنهم من
فنيين وتقنيين او عاملين في اقسام اخرى
هؤلاء الجنود المجهولون اتذكرهم تذكر
المؤسسين في البدايه وهؤلاء يعرفون انفسهم
لن اسميهم حتى لا ارتكب خطا نسيان احدهم
ايضا الطالب سؤال وجدان يا اخير بماذا
سيخبر حسين فياض قنيبر مع حفظ الالقاب
اولاده ولاحقا احفاده ان شاء الله عن قناه
العربيه باختصار
ساقول لهم انها المحطه التي اعطتني فرصه
ليس فرصه العمل بالضروره طالب ما هو اهم
من ذلك بكثير لان العمل يمكن ان نجده في
قنوات اخرى الاهم من العمل هو ان قناه
العربيه اعطتني فرصه ان امارس هذه المهنه
مع الحفاظ على اكبر قدر من الحريه كي
احافظ على قيم اعلاميه تؤمن بها العربيه
سواء في البروموشن الذي تردده دائما دقه
وموضوعيه او في المقدمه التي ذكرتها في
نشرتك الاولى على المحطه المهنيه
والموضوعيه والخبر السريع اعطتني هامشا
لاحافظ على هذه القيم الاعلاميه الدقه ثم
الدقه والموضوعيه ثم الموضوعيه لان
المشاهد ينسى لك 100 خبر صحيح ويبقى عالقا
في ذاكرته خبر واحد غير دقيقته هي الاساس
وشكرا للعربيه التي اعطتنا هذا الهامش
للحفاظ على الدقه شكرا لك حسين وينعاد
عليك على بال 100 سنه حسين العربيه من
باريس
لمزيد ايضا في هذه التغطيه ينضم الي من
الكويت الان وزير الاعلام الكويتيه الاسبق
الدكتور سعد بن طفله العجمي دكتور سعد
اهلا وسهلا بك انت من الوجوه الاولى التي
اطلت عبر قناه العربيه سواء في البرامج
كمحلل كمثقف حتى يعني في برنامج حوار
العرب معي استضافتك اكثر من مره في برنامج
تحت الضوء
ما الذي يعنيه بالنسبه اليك دكتور سعد
العربيه ولماذا انت كمثقف مع حفظ الالقاب
تشاهد العربيه
احييك يا صديقي ومشاهديك الكرام واقول لكم
ولنا جميعا كل عام وانتم بخير
انا يعني عايشت العربيه منذ خطواتها
الاولى وكنت يعني ممن سائر ومسيرتها وعايش
مسيرتها منذ انطلاقتها قبل 20 عام
وانا الحقيقه اشعر بانني من اهل الدار من
كثر ما انا تابعت العربيه ومثل ما تفضل
نحن الضيوف وانت رفض المنزلي يا دكتور سعد
العفو يا سيدي شكرا جزيلا
والعربيه يعني نافذه واسعه على الموضوعيه
والمهنيه والحقيقه
واعتقد بان هذه النافذه
يعني كفتنا الكثير من فتح نوافذ اخرى كنا
نضطر او كان المشاهد العربي يضطر الى
اللجوء اليها من بسبب قله النوافذ فكان من
خلال
نافذه العربيه يتنفس كثيرا من الموضوعيه
وكثيرا من الدقه وكثيرا من سرعه الخبر
الذي يميز العربيه حقيقه وانا اقولها يعني
كاحد اولئك الذين مارسوا او استمتعوا بتلك
الميزه هي انني قد خرجت واخرين على قناه
العربيه لننتقل العربيه وكانت تقبل هذا
الانتقاد وهذه من النوادر الحقيقه في
اعلامنا العربي تعرف اعلامنا العربي يجب
ان تشيد نقطه وان تقول بان كل شيء على ما
يرام لابد من النقد للعربيه من اجل المزيد
من العطاء لانني اعتقد بان زاد
العطام هو بنقده والاعلام الذي لا يتعرض
به النقد والجدل احد امرين اما انه قران
منزل وهذا غير موجود
اعتقد بان ما لا يثير الجدل ليس باعلامي
وليس له ثمن والعربيه هي النافذه التي
تثير الجدل وتعطي الخبر وتعطي الموضوعيه
وتعطي المهنيه
تهنئه يعني رائع جدا خصوصا خصوصا مصطلح
النقد هي الناس بيفهموا النقد على انه شيء
سيء علما ان النقد يعني كمصطلح هو قراءه
اي شيء قراءه علميه ساسالك بعد قليل عن
يعني عن العربيه هل هي خارج مستوى النقد
ما لها وما عليها ولكن تعرف المشاهدين
يريدون ان اسالك بعض الاسئله التقليديه
اولا ما الذي تتذكره اكثر من غيره من
احداث تابعتها على قناه العربيه دكتور سعد
اعتقد بان
الاهم في مسيره العربيه كان بدايه
انطلاقتها ولنعترف بانها قد مرت بمطبات
اعلاميه هائله في البدايه لانها تزامنت مع
حرب اسقاط نظام صدام حسين اي تلك
الانطلاقه وكان على الاقل من الزاويه
الكويتيه ومن الزاويه العراقيه نتابع
العربيه ونقارنها بالتغطيات الاخرى فكان
من الواضح تماما بانها مرت بمط
بات حجه ان دائما الخطوات الاولى ويعني هي
التي تكون متعثره في البدايه هذا التعثر
ربما زادها صلابه فيما بعد
وهو الى ما اوصلها اليه اليوم بمعنى انها
لم تقل منذ البدايه انا شاشه كامله ولا
اعتقد بانها ستجرى لليوم
ولا بس
بب امنه لذلك تقدم نفسها دوما بانها
الاقرب الى الحقيقه احاول بكل تواضع ان
تقول انا مو الحقيقه ولكني الحقيقه وهذا
بحد ذاته انعكاس يعني هذا الشعار بحد ذاته
يعكس المهنيا دكتور سعد هل كان هنالك
ضروره اعلاميه وسياسيه ماسه لوجود قناه
العربيه
ام لا برايك الامر يتعلق بالسوق الاعلامي
حسابات الربع والخساره
ساترك الربح والخساره يعني للاخرين لكن
انا اتكلم عن الضروره القصوى لوجود
منظار ينظر من خلال المشاهد العربي الى ما
يجري حول من احداث مع غطته وتغطيه العربيه
وما قدمته من تضحيات وما قدمته من جهد وما
قدمته من حتى يتوتر وانا اعرف الحقيقه
كثير من العاملين هي العربيه الذين يعني
تعرضوا الى كثير من التوتر
وكثير من الضغوط لانه اعرفهم الله يعينكم
انا اعرف انت ايضا استاذ يعني كنعان من
الذين يعني يتعرضون ويعيشون هذا التوتر
ولكن يجب ان تدركوا بان المشاهد الكريم
يقدر لكم هذه التضحيات ويقدر بانكم تعيشون
على اعصابكم احيانا وعلى حبل مشدود من اجل
اولا السرعه من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
والموضوعيه وفي نفس الوقت لا تستطيع باي
حال من الاحوال ان ترضي كل المشاهدين
يكون التواضع وهنا تكون
شكرا شكرا لهذه الشهاده سؤال اخير دكتور
سعد كما قلنا لا شيء خارج اطار النقد
والعربيه ليست فوق النقد هل يمكن اعطاء
قراءه نقديه وافيه الان لقناه العربيه ما
لها وما عليها
لا وافيه معناتها اقعد معاك لليل بس
لانه ما في شيء وافي لكن
ان نقول بان العربيه تقبل هامش واسع من
النقد لها على شاشتها وهذا يسجل لها وهذا
دليل على نضجها بعد مرور عقدين على
انشائها واتمنى لها طول العمر وطول
الاستمرار وطول ومزيد من المهنيه
والموضوعيه والقرب من الحقيقه نتمنى لك
مفور الصحه وينعاد عليك الدكتور سعد بن
طفله العجمي وزير الاعلام الكويتيه الاسبق
من الكويت شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
انا بعتقد من اللحظات الاولى كان واضح
العربيه انه ستكون هي المحطه العربيه
التي لن تقف
لحظات الاولى انا وزملائي اللي كانوا افضل
مني حتى
كان في احساس انه هذا النجاح هذا النجاح
مؤكد ومستمر والعربيه ماضيه والعربيه
حقيقه الان انا بعتقد انه بالوطن العربي
كل العرب يتابعوا العربيه
[موسيقى]
العربيه قناه مهمه جدا في الاعلام العربي
وقناه رئيسيه
الاعلام العربي يعاني من
النقص بلاش اكثر من كده
النقص المهنيه
وبالتالي في المصداقيه العربيه سدت جزء
كبير من هذا النقص
وقبل ان نواصل التغطيه اعزائي المشاهدين
نتابع معكم لمحات من تاريخ مذيعيه ومذيعات
العربيه نسال الله السلامه من مقالب بعض
الزملاء
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه ان القوات الامريكيه
الاخبار
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
الذين لقوا حطفهم في العراق منذ اندلاع
الحرب عام 2003
بدا منهم صالح العوفي القيادي البارز في
تنظيم القاعده في قلل المتحدث باسم اللجنه
المشرفه على الانتخاب عقد في غياب رئيس
الفلسطينيه ياسر عرفات
[موسيقى]
معي الان في الاستوديو الزميل زياد عبيدات
المذيعه رياضي في قناه العربيه زياد
ذكريات
ينعاد عليك وعقبال 100 سنه كل عام وانتم
بخير كل عام والعربيه وجميله ان شاء الله
بالف خير اتشرف طالب بانني كنت اول مذيع
في قناه العربيه اول من قدم نشره اخبار
الرياضه في قناه العربيه اتشرف ايضا
بالجلوس امام اول شخص واول مذيع
ظهر على شاشه
طبعا انا كان عمري ايام 17 سنه انت كل ما
بتقدر
الا انا زياد اهلا وسهلا بك انت من الرعيل
الاول الرعيل المؤسس ما الذي تتذكره
فعليا وتحديدا من تلك المرحله وكيف كان
يعني انا بشكر انه نحن جينا انا جيت لهون
سبتمبر وكانت مرحله تاسيس والتحضير شي سته
اشهر
كنا مساء على الساعه الخامسه صباحا
نجي لهون نعمل حوالي الاربع خمس نشرات
يعني تح
وكان الزملاء عم ينضموا لالنا تباعا انتم
في قسم الرياضه
كنتم موجودين ايضا في مرحله التاسيس شو
اللي بتتذكر من تلك المرحله وكيف كانت
اتذكر كل شيء يا طالب طبعا التحضيرات بدات
بقياده عراب الرياضه في ذلك الوقت رئيس
القسم الرياضي الاستاذ حيدر الوتار حيدر
زرع فينا الثقه من البدايه بدا معنا من
الصفر حتى نقدم اجمل محتوى لساده
المشاهدين في الوطن العربي حيدر علمنا كل
اشي اوكي يعني وكاننا جايين للاعلام لاول
مره
ساعات العمل امتدت من ثمان الى عشر ساعات
يوميا لمده من اربعه الى خمسه اشهر طبعا
كنا معكم خلال النشاط التجريبيه على مدى
هذه الشهور يوم الانطلاقه طالب كان الاجمل
الجميع بحاله تاهب توجهت الى الاستوديو
ظليت اتفرج على الكرسي فقط كرسي الاخبار
اللي بدي اجلس عليه واقدم اول نشره اخبار
في قناه العربيه او ذاكر ايمتى وشو كان
الخبر زياد اول خبر عن بطوله كاس العالم
للشباب التي اقيمت في الامارات
اي ساعه ذاكر باي نشره الساعه السابعه
مساء بتوقيت دبي اول ضيف كان سعاده مطر
الطاير مدير هيئه الطرق والمواصلات حاليا
في دبي خلال هذه اللحظات قبل الانطلاقه
قبل ما اروح على الكرسي التهيت ونسيت
النشره جالس مع احد الزملاء واحد بيحكي يا
زياد يا زياد الناس نسيت طلعت على كرسي
الاخبار قبل ثواني معدوده هنا بدا تاريخ
الاحترافي في قناه العربيه هذه اخبار
الرياضه من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم كنت
متهيب من تلك اللحظه شي زياد خايف
نحكي ليله الانطلاقه كان في خوف يعني ظليت
اشوف طول الليل انه ملايين من الناس
بتابعونا يوم الانطلاقه ابدا اختفى كل هذا
الامر بسبب دعم استاذنا العزيز حيدر
الوتار اعطانا
مضحكه صارت معكن او احداث ممكن تخبرنا
للمشاهد في هذا التاريخ الطويل والحفل شوف
خلال التحضيرات يعني كلنا اجينا من بلدان
مختلفين اللي اجى من تونس اللي اجى من
المغرب يعني اللهجات كانت مختلفه تماما
زميلنا العزيز حماد القردبو تونسي
التونسيه طبعا مختلفه تماما
يتصل مع مراسل العربيه في الاردن محمد
العزا يطلب منه تقرير مثلا عن كره القدم
محمد روحي ودي تقرير عن كرات السله
حمادي يتصل يعاتب ويعمل مشاكل مع محمد
العزه بالاخير المراسل محمد العزي حكى له
والله يا حمادي والله ما بفهم عليك شو
بتحكي ههه
على كل زياد ينعاد عليك وشكرا جزيلا جزيلا
لك دائما انت من الراعي الاول والرعيل
المؤسس يعطيكم الف عافيه كل عام وانتم
بخير ينعاد عليكم
منذ بدايات العربيه كان قدرها تغطيات
موسعه في مختلف بلدان العالم لاحداث لم
ولن تنسى جهود كبيره بذلها مراسلوا
العربيه ولا يزالون لتعرفوا اكثر نستذكر
معكم هنا بعض تغطيات العربيه قبل نحو
عشرين عاما
[موسيقى]
يشهد عدد من المدن والمناطق الافغانيه
موجه من العنف المتقطع عشيه الانتخابات
التاريخيه
اضاف الملا عبيد في تسجيل صوتي حصلت عليه
العربيه لذلك فاننا لن نقبل هذه
الانتخابات كما يتعلق بنوعيه الحبر الذي
يصبغ به ابهام الناخبين
كسر رئيس الامريكي جورج بوش الامريكيين
على التفكير في مساله الامن
تعتبر معقلا ليس للجمهوريين وحسب
[موسيقى]
دعا ابو مازن كافه الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى
التكاثف استمرار عمل جميع الهيئات
القياديه في اطار السلطه الوطنيه التي
اجريت حتى الان تستبعد وجود اي علامه
لسرطان على بعد امطار من هنا يرقد ابو
عمار مترنحا بين الحياه والموت
تحضيرا لدفن جثمان الرئيس الفلسطينيه سر
عرفات مرحله تاريخيه جديده بدات برحيل
عرفات
[موسيقى]
ارتفعت حصيله الكارثه الطبيعيه التي ضربت
منطقه جنوب اسيا الى نحو عشره الاف قتيل
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته 80 درجات فاصل
تسعه على مقياس
[موسيقى]
اقوى زلزال يضرب العالم
من الفوضى وتم سحب عدد كبير من هذه الكره
الذين حاولوا العوده الى مناطق المنكوفه
كره كامله مدمره ومدن مشونه تامه
الحصيله المرشحه لزياده كل ساعه تحدثت عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن 30 الف شخص في سبع دول
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه مستمره
تسحبكم في الساعه المقبله الزميله ريما
مكتبي التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته